SPEAKER: The following content
is provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of
MIT courses, visit
mitopencourseware@ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So let
me just start out
by giving you a quick overview
of what we're going to be doing
today, what the plan is.
I'm going to spend the first
maybe third or so of the time
or maybe hopefully less than
that talking very generally
about basic camera
concepts, and if you
have some video experience
or if you have some still
photography experience,
they're going
to be pretty familiar to you.
I'm going to keep
it fairly general,
and we're going to go
through fairly quickly
some basic things in order to
lay the groundwork for the more
exciting and interesting
part, which is actually
going out and shooting.
But after I finish that, then
Dave is going to take over
and he's going to provide you
with a very quick introduction
to our camera, where
the controls are,
how things are set up, how
to do some of the things
that I'm talking about
specifically with our camera.
And then we're all going
to go out and have a chance
to actually shoot some stuff,
which should be a lot of fun.
So that's the story, and I'm
just going to jump right in.
Although I guess I
should ask first,
does anyone have any questions
or thoughts from Wednesday
night?
OK, well, what
we're trying to do
is build every session
on the last one.
And so I'm going to start
out by referencing something
that I talked about last time.
The way that we began, which was
looking at another visual art.
Painting.
And if I asked you what
the tools and the medium
of a painter were, you would
have a pretty easy answer,
right?
I mean, it's paint, it's canvas.
It's the stuff that you
use to make a painting.
Same with sculpture.
Stone, steel, mud, bricks,
whatever it may be.
So the question then is,
what's the medium for film
and what are the tools of film?
Some are obvious, obviously.
The camera, exactly.
That's kind of the brush.
I mean, not exactly, but
that's the basic tool.
But what else?
What are the other
tools of the filmmaker?
Light.
Others?
So the actual what
you record on.
Exactly, and how
you manipulate that.
But there are lots
of others as well,
and a concept that I find really
useful and interesting in just
thinking about what you do as
a filmmaker or a video maker,
and I'm going to use those
terms interchangeably,
as I said on Wednesday, are
what we call or it can be called
the plastic elements of film.
And by that, I just
mean the elements
that you as the artist, the
filmmaker have control over
and that you can change at will.
So the camera.
What you choose to do with the
camera is, obviously, extremely
important and in fact
central to the outcome
and to what you want to do as
an artist or as a documentarian.
Lighting, again.
Whether you're actually adding
lights, setting up lights,
doing very complex
lighting setups
or just using available light.
How you choose to place
your subject in relation
to the sun, how you choose to
light the lights in a room.
These fluorescent
lights above us.
We're taping this
for OpenCourseWare,
and before everyone
came, we tried
a couple of different settings
for the overhead lights.
And so that is, again,
a plastic element.
But there are others too.
Can you think of others?
The lens, yeah.
What lens you use to
shoot with, exactly.
Others?
Yeah, exactly.
The scene, the setting.
Could be the location.
Another way of
thinking about it.
So if you're doing-- and that's
obviously true of a fiction
film, but it's also
true of a documentary.
If you're interviewing somebody,
where do you choose to put them
and what does where
you choose to put
them say about your subject?
What do you want it to say?
You have control over
that and you have--
in a lot of ways, you have
as much or as little control
as you want, because you
can be very interventionist
and place them exactly where
you want them or you can just
do whatever happens.
If you went to interview
a professor here at MIT
and you found them
in their office,
you just could do
it right there.
And that would say something
about them as well.
Do you clean the office or
do you not clean the office?
That's another thing.
So if you think
about it like that,
then suddenly, this whole world
of elements opens up, right?
Props, how you arrange
things in a scene.
Whether you dress
the set, and again,
whether it's a documentary or a
fiction film, it still applies.
Sound.
How you record the sound,
whether you record the sound,
what you do in editing in
order to change things,
if you add music, if you
mix the sound, if you add
sound effects, and editing
itself is a plastic element.
That's almost as
important as the camera.
It's a central tool
for the filmmaker,
how you edit a piece.
So there are any number--
and these are just a few.
Any number of plastic
elements that you can control,
and I think this is just
like a central idea that
seems obvious, but
it's also something
that you want to
continually remind yourself,
because I know that in my
experience as a producer
or a director and doing a lot
of other things in film as well,
you can sometimes forget
that you have the ability
to change things, because
sometimes you're rushed,
you don't have time, or
fate deals you a blow
that you feel you
have to accept.
But you just remember that
you can take the initiative
and change something.
So if the location doesn't
work, the beautiful idea you had
is not going to happen.
Improvise and think
of something else.
You have the power to change
a lot of these things.
So today, we're going
to talk about camera,
which is in many ways, first and
foremost, the plastic element.
It's the first one that was
mentioned here when I asked you
about what kinds of
things you use as a tool,
and it's obviously
the fundamental thing,
because everything is
passing through the lens.
And I want to just provide a
very, very brief introduction
to some of the really basic
ideas in filmmaking, which
are very similar in many ways
to some of the basic ideas
in still photography
if you've done that.
And one way to think about them,
one way I like to think about
them are as the four F's.
F-stop, or exposure, focus,
focal length, and framing.
And there are others, but
they don't start with F,
but I like to start with these.
And F-stop is also
maybe a bit simplistic
when you're talking
about exposure.
But it's just a way
to remember them.
F-stop, focus, focal
length, framing.
And I'm just going to spend a
couple of minutes on each one,
and don't expect to
absorb it all right now.
It's the kind of
thing that's going
to make a lot more sense
when you're filming.
So I'm not going to get really
hung up on a lot of details.
This isn't a class on
optics or the physics
of light or anything
like that, but I
want to just introduce
a couple of terms.
So first, exposure.
F-stop or aperture is one
of the basic things that
controls what your
exposure of your camera is,
and that is basically
in simplistic terms
or in simple terms how much
light is entering the camera
lens.
How much light is
hitting the sensor
that's recording the image?
And lenses are equipped with
an aperture that is adjustable.
So you see at the
top there, there's
an aperture that's very
wide, it's very open,
which in terms of F-stop
is a very low number, F2,
and at the bottom of
that very same lens,
the aperture is almost
completely shut.
It's just almost a pinhole,
and that corresponds
to a very high F, number F22.
And lenses, you'll see that
the lenses on our cameras
can be adjusted.
You can either leave
it in auto and let
the camera choose what
the exposure should be,
or you can choose it.
And obviously,
the more light you
have in a scene, the more
stop down or the smaller
the aperture would be in order
to get the correct exposure.
In other words, in order to
have enough light hitting
your sensor but
not too much light
in order to get a
good looking image.
Just also quickly, F-stop
is not the only way
to adjust exposure.
You do have other controls.
You have the shutter speed.
The shutter speed is basically
determining how much time
each frame of your
video or your film
is exposed to light
as it goes by.
And you can adjust it, but
in this video and film,
you normally aren't
going to adjust it.
You normally want to keep it
for normal appearing motion
at about 1/60 of a second.
So in practical
terms, unless you're
shooting something
that's a very high speed
activity or some kind
of special situation
or you're maybe in a very,
very low light situation,
you don't want to use the
shutter as an exposure control.
Mainly, you're going
to keep it at 160.
Yes, sir?
TA: It's usually
double the frame rate.
So if it's like if you're
shooting 24 frames per second,
it would be 1 over 48.
PROFESSOR: Right, and we're
shooting 30 frames per second,
so that's why it's 160, yeah.
The second thing is the
camera sensitivity itself.
Different cameras have a
different sensitivity to light,
and you'll very quickly come to
both appreciate and hate some
of the quirks of our camera.
It is sensitive compared
to some and not as others,
so it depends on what
you may be expecting.
You can also, however, there
are adjustments to cameras
and video cameras basically.
It's called the gain control.
So if the lighting
situation is very poor,
you don't have a lot of
light, the gain can be raised.
But the trade off is that the
image gets very, very fuzzy.
Much lower resolution.
But there is that sensitivity.
And then finally, of
course, there are lights.
You can add light.
Either by changing the
location, going from--
if one room is too dark and
the next room isn't, you
can change the rooms.
If you have lights,
you can add them.
We actually are--
for this class,
we're shooting available
light for the most part.
There will be one
class on lighting,
but we don't have
lighting packages that
are going to be
generally available,
but there are ways
to overcome that clip
lights, regular consumer
lights, and people in this class
have done interesting things
with those kinds of things
in the past.
So anyway, lots of ways
to control exposure,
the essential basic one
is the F stopper aperture.
So let's go on to focus, the
second F. First thing to know
is that just like with
exposure, this camera and almost
all video cameras have two
settings, auto and manual.
Manual focus is almost always
preferred, because just as
with exposure, the auto
setting can be fooled.
It will breathe, so
it'll change its mind
and focus on something else
in the middle of a shot which
can be very distracting
and annoying.
So in almost all
situations you're
going to want to stay manual,
both for F-stop and for focus.
But you do have that option.
You do have auto as
a choice, and there
are situations, where
it's better to be on auto
than to be nothing, right?
I mean, if you grab the camera
because there's a flying saucer
landing outside and you want to
get the shot, if it's an auto,
it's much better to have
something than to have nothing
and to be adjusting.
But generally, we discourage
the use of auto focus and auto
iris.
Second thing to think about with
focus is the depth of field.
Depth of field is
basically a term
that refers to how much of your
image in terms of the depth
is in focus?
So if you're shooting
me sitting here
talking as our camera person
is, hopefully, I'm in focus.
The background behind me
doesn't have to be in focus,
and it might or
might not be in focus
depending on the aperture
that the camera is set up.
So a very wide aperture because
it's a low light situation
means that you have
very shallow focus,
and the background
may be out of focus.
The smaller the aperture
gets, the deeper your focus
is so that the background
suddenly could become in focus.
And this is something that you
can-- it's an aesthetic choice.
It's not just determined
by your lighting,
although that's
obviously something
you have to deal with, but
you can actually make choices
about what's in focus and what's
not, and how deep the focus is
and in it and it has an
impact on how people read
the images that you create.
I don't if anybody
here is nearsighted,
but if you want to get a
sense of how depth of field
is determined by the aperture,
you can take your glasses off,
and you can actually do this.
And the smaller you
make the pinhole
that you're looking through,
the more in focus you are
or what you're seeing is.
And it doesn't really work
if you're everything's
always in focus for you.
But for me, it
works really well.
So if I don't have my glasses in
the morning, I can look at you
and I can see that
you're quite sharp if I
make the pinhole small enough.
So anyway, it's kind
of a cool effect.
And it gives you a sense that,
basically, what's happening
is that the smaller the aperture
that the light is passing
through, the more aligned,
and again, this is not
an optics class and I'm not
going to go too far down
this road that I
don't know much about,
but the light is more
aligned, there's less scatter,
and that makes everything
in sharper focus.
So again, focus is something
that is extremely important.
So is exposure.
They're non-negotiable.
The first two F's are, either
you did it or you didn't.
You're either in
focus or you're not.
And you pretty much
want to be in focus
and you pretty much want
to be properly exposed.
You don't want to have too
much light hitting your image,
you don't want to
have too little.
Even if you want to manipulate
focus or exposure later
because you want to actually
have things appear out
of focus, it's much
better to do it
in editing and
post-production than to do it
when you're shooting, because
you can't change it back.
You can't make a
blurry image sharp.
You can make a
sharp image blurry.
You can take a very
well exposed image
and make it dark or bright,
but you can't very easily
take a dark image and
make it properly exposed.
So these first two,
as I said, I usually
refer to them as the
non-negotiable two.
The next two, however,
are infinitely negotiable.
Focal length refers
to whether you're
shooting something
in a wide angle
or a telephoto or
a normal setting.
And again, you may
have some experience
with still photography.
Wide angle lens
are the lenses that
are a smaller number
of millimeters,
like the 12 millimeter lens,
the 6 millimeter lens, the 16
millimeter lens.
Telephoto are the big numbers.
200, 300, and 150.
And each of them give you very,
very, very different feeling
kinds of images.
The wide angle lens gives
you a much wider angle
of view, obviously.
So if you're filming
landscapes, you
can put a wide angle
lens on your camera,
and from the same position,
get a much wider field.
It also gives you
much deeper focus.
To go back to the idea of depth
of field, with a wide angle
lens, it's much easier to
get everything in focus
from the foreground
to the background.
Telephoto lenses,
on the other hand,
are a much narrower
angle of view.
So if I'm standing in the same
place filming the same thing,
I'm seeing a much
narrower field,
which can also be thought
of as magnification, right?
So same image, but now, if I'm
filming the camera person who's
filming me, I'm
seeing just his face
instead of the whole field.
And the focus, the depth of
field, is much shallower.
So it's much easier to
get a nice soft background
on a telephoto lens.
Just one other note
about focal length.
Again, it's something that
is infinitely variable
and you can choose
as a filmmaker
what kinds of focal lengths
you use, but don't confuse
a wide angle lens with a
wide shot or a telephoto lens
with a close up.
It's easier to get a close
up with a telephoto lens
and it's easier to get a wide
shot with a wide angle lens,
but it's certainly possible to
do a wide shot with a telephoto
lens.
You just have to be much farther
away from your subject and vise
versa.
It's very possible to do a
close up with a wide angle lens,
you just have to
get much closer.
But they'll feel
very, very different,
and I'll show you some extreme
examples here in a minute.
So this is an extreme
wide angle lens.
What we call a fish eye lens.
And you'll see, first of all,
that it's very distorted,
but you're seeing a very,
very wide field of view.
So wide, in fact, that the
only way to accommodate
is the distortion.
You're also seeing
incredible depth of field.
The background, the
infinite distance
is sharp, and so is
the hand that's not
that far away from the camera.
It also wide angle lenses--
and this is an extreme example.
Wide angle lenses tend
to distort and elongate
the distance between objects.
So that hand is much closer to
the camera than it might appear
and the distance between the
hand and every other element
going back is
somewhat elongated.
So it makes smaller
rooms feel much bigger,
it makes distances
seem much greater.
Telephoto lens.
The long lens, because
they're long, do the opposite.
So here, we have a
telephoto shot of a bird,
and you see first of all that
the background is very, very
soft, even though it's not that
far really behind the bird,
and things are very compressed.
So the distance between
the bird and the background
feels like there's not
much distance at all,
even though there might
actually be quite a lot.
One of the things
about telephoto lenses
is that sometimes
the depth of field
is so shallow that
you can literally
have the eye of the bird in
focus and the background that
of the plant that it's standing
on completely soft here.
The plant is actually in focus.
But if you're
doing an interview,
a human eye might be
in focus and their ear
might be out of focus at
an extreme telephoto lens.
So this is actually
aesthetically really pleasing,
because the foreground
jumps out at you.
Our eye goes
immediately to the bird
and the background
just drops off
into this very soft,
nice backplate.
So again, I could shoot
a wide shot like this,
but it would look
extremely different
than shooting a wide shot
with a wide angle lens.
So now, let's talk
about framing.
And framing, this is really--
once you master the basics
of the camera framing
is a catchall term for
everything else about how
you choose to shoot things.
Do you choose to
shoot close ups?
Do you shoot choose
to shoot wide shots?
What's the grammar of film?
And we're not going to do
any kind of exhaustive talk
about that right now,
but it's an infinitely
interesting and
inexhaustible subject.
Sabrina, you mentioned
that on Wednesday night,
when we were looking at
those very early films,
everything was
filmed head to toe.
And that was because
I mean there really
hadn't been a grammar of
film developed at that point.
They were just thinking
about them as stage plays.
So people would walk in head to
toe and they'd do their thing
and they'd walk out.
But a few years
after that, people
started filming close ups, and
that was a huge revolution.
They started filming shots
of the hands of people
doing things.
They started moving
the camera so
that it would pan from one
person to another and back.
They started filming
shots with someone
in the foreground and
someone in the background,
and then they'd do a
reverse with this person
in the foreground and this
person in the background.
And that kind of opened up this
whole language that all of us--
we're used to reading this
language because we've
been doing it our entire
lives, but at that point,
it was an extremely new.
What shot works with this shot?
What's confusing,
what's not confusing?
How do we understand a scene?
And all of that is
related to framing.
So we're going to be looking at
a lot of films in this class.
We're going to be talking about
why they were shot the way they
were shot, both in terms
of the social terms
and the technical terms,
the technological terms,
but also in terms of the
framing and the grammar of them.
And it's something
that you're going
to gain a lot of experience
and understanding
of as you make your own films.
But just for starters, I'm going
to talk a little bit about just
some basic ideas and concepts
that you might want to think
about as you frame a scene.
Let's take this
class, for instance.
How would I film this class?
There are an infinite number
of ways that I could do it.
It's being filmed right now
for a very particular reason.
A very particular purpose,
OpenCourseWare is filming it,
and the way they're
filming it is
by focusing on me because
I'm the one talking
and on the slides,
because it's information
that they're trying to capture.
If we were filming it
for other purposes,
we could have a completely
different approach.
We could film it as a
documentary cinema verite
direct cinema style, which is if
you remember the scene the John
F. Kennedy documentary about
the primary in Wisconsin
that we watched the clip
of on Wednesday night.
That was all about the
experience of being there,
and it had a very
particular point
of view, the experience
of Jackie Kennedy and JFK
in that room shaking
a million hands being
pushed by the crowd.
So if we were going to film
this class in that way,
we could use a handheld
camera, that camera
could be completely mobile.
If I'm not what's
important to the filmmaker,
I might barely be in it.
Maybe it's a film about you
and they're following you
in your day and I'm
just this droning
voice in the background.
What they're interested
in is your response
to the environment and
how to capture that.
So it'd be completely
different way
of filming this and the
framing and the shot choices
would be completely
different than what
we're doing right now.
We could film it with
multiple cameras.
We could film as we
did the other night.
We could have a camera
pointing at students,
camera in the background,
we can edit it together.
How we shoot people,
whether we're shooting them
in close ups or wide shots all
has a really significant impact
on the story that we're telling.
And one of the things
with documentary film
is that as a camera
person, again,
let's say that we're doing a
day in the life of Sabrina.
As the story unfolds, we're
constantly making adjustments.
We're constantly making new
choices about what to film.
So if we're filming
your experience
of being in this class, as that
experience changes as a camera
person, the camera
person would need
to be sensitive to that change.
So let's say you got into a
discussion and a disagreement
with Dave, our TA.
Because you didn't agree
with his interpretation
of something, which will happen.
No, no.
So suddenly, we would
be focusing on Dave
and your response to Dave.
So we would be in close ups on
you listening to Dave, looking
unhappy, arguing back.
Suddenly, we're on Dave, Dave
is talking back and forth,
back and forth, and
me, the instructor
who is being filmed right now,
I'm not even in the picture.
It doesn't matter what I'm
saying or thinking or doing.
Then we're the
camera person starts
looking for up reaction
shots of other students.
Does everyone agree with or
does everyone agree with Dave
and think you're wrong?
And as you make that
choice as a camera person,
it's going to impact
who you choose to film.
So we touched on the idea
of fairness and accuracy
in the documentary film.
What you choose to frame
and how you choose to frame
it has a huge, huge impact
on the story that you tell.
So you can walk into that
situation I just described
and film it with
an agenda, like we
want to make Sabrina
look like the smartest
person in the room.
So then you film it
in a certain way,
or we want to show how
completely isolated she is,
film it in a different way.
Or you could be very sensitive
and open to the situation
and adjust and try to be make an
accurate or fair representation
of what's actually happening.
And believe me that both are
common in documentary film.
I mean, going in with an
agenda is extremely common,
and that's not the same as lying
quote, unquote "manipulating",
although there is an element
of manipulation to it.
But generally, we do go in
with preconceived notions
and it impacts how we frame
things and how we shoot things.
So anyway, that's
the overall thing.
We're not going to talk
about a lot of film grammar
right now because I could go
on for the rest of the time
and I'd rather get on to
the actual camera work.
But I am going to--
I am going to just raise a
couple of things to think about
since you very soon have
cameras in your hands
and just basic kinds of
things to think about
as you choose the shots
that you're going to film.
First of all, there's
a real tendency when
you get a camera for the
first time-- and I mean,
I'm sure everyone at this
point is filmed something
with a video camera.
There's a real tendency to
want to capture everything.
So we're in this room, we're
filming, and you think,
oh, I'm going to get
everything, and you
start doing this, which is
basically moving continually,
because that's how
our eyes work, right?
I'm just looking around,
I see everything.
So you just assume the
camera works that way, too.
But what you end up doing
is capturing nothing,
because with the camera you have
to fake the way your eye works,
and the way your eye
works is I'm doing this
and I'm seeing everything,
but I'm also continuously--
my brain is continuously
picking out things
and making close
ups out of the stuff
that I see making
different angles.
So when I was talking
about suddenly
there was a close up of
even though I saw everything
else too.
When I talked about
Dave, suddenly
there was a close up of
Dave in my head, right?
So the camera has
to do that, and you
have to make it do
that, which means
that what they call hosing
down the room, which
is this continual I don't
want to miss anything
so I'm just going
to keep doing this,
it just ends up with mush.
And you're not telling a
story and you're not really
getting any shots that
you're able to edit.
So you want to be deliberate
about what you're shooting
and you want to think
about what you're shooting.
What story am I
telling and what images
do I need to tell that story?
Do I need to focus on you?
Do I need to focus on Dave?
Do I need to shoot a wide
shot that establishes
the geography of
the room so that I
know where people are sitting.
Second thing is
very basic thing.
Hold your shots.
There's also a tendency
that goes along
with this hosing down the
room to never really hold
on anything.
So I'm filming Sabrina,
but then suddenly, I
want to go over here and
then I want to go back,
and then I end up
with nothing again.
So you we want to make a choice
and then stick with it for
long enough that you
actually get something.
So if I'm shooting
a close up of Chris
listening to me
skeptically, I want
to hold on for a certain
number of seconds
and then go back to the next
thing that I want to shoot.
And it can be hard sometimes,
because suddenly, something
really interesting is
happening over there
and you want to run
over and get it,
and you need to be responsive
to that and obviously pay
attention to it.
But if you get too
caught up in the moment,
you end up with
nothing, and this
is something that is
a real struggle even
for professional camera
people sometimes,
because they have all of this
information bombarding them
about what they want
to do and some of them,
especially people who come
from still photography,
maybe don't hold the
shots long enough.
There's kind of a rule of the
nice long, slow count to 10
before you then pan
away to something else.
Could be count to five if the
action is a little faster.
But just remember, frame
something up, hold the shot,
and then move on.
And then the idea also when
you're moving the camera
is think about why
you're moving the camera.
Why would you move
the camera rather than
just to hose down the room?
OK, any basic ideas?
Well, if I'm moving--
if I have a camera, why would
I actually start doing this?
Why would I actually move?
Well, compared to just moving
like this randomly or not
moving at all.
What would motivate me to
move the camera around?
Right.
Yeah, exactly.
So following an action.
And it might be actually
a physical action.
I mean, if I'm profiling
Chris and suddenly she
gets up and goes over to
really getting Dave's face
to really argue
with them, I would
want to follow them, right?
But if they're just
talking even cordially,
I don't know why I always
bring you to conflict, David.
I don't--
TA: It's just who I am.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, you just
draw it out of people.
But even if they're just
they're speaking, as you say,
I would be panning
back and forth.
And at some point, I might
come over here and film Dave
and start filming from
his point of view.
So that's the situation.
You want to try to make
your moves motivated
by something not just by
random hosing down of the room.
So that's, again, just a really
basic concept, and all of this
is-- it's going to make a
lot more sense when you start
shooting, and it's really
going to make sense
when you start editing, because
editing is the part where
you really learn how to shoot.
I think all people
who shoot should
edit, even if they don't
want to be editors,
because that's when you
really learn what's working
and what's not working
in your shooting.
A couple of other quick tips.
Remember that although film
is a two dimensional art form
and your images are all 2D,
you're representing a 3D world,
and that means that
you want to think
about ways to create depth
in your frame, which means,
essentially, different
planes of action.
So again, if I'm
filming Chris and Dave,
if I come around
like this, and I
shoot Chris's shoulder in
the foreground and Dave
in the far background, that's
kind of a nice deep shot,
because we get a
sense of the room,
we get a sense
that there's depth,
that there's a dimensionality
to the conversation.
And then I can go over and
I can do the same this way.
I also might still shoot close
ups and edit it all together.
But what would be
weird and disorienting
would be, again, if they're
having a conversation
and I just filmed a close up
of Chris and then I went over
and I filmed a close
up of Dave and I never
had any sense of the
relationship in space
or what the room was like or
anything else, because then
you just have this head
floating in space over here,
head floating in
space over there
with no kind of
relationship between them
and no kind of three
dimensionality.
So again, using depth
of field, using--
even if something is out
of focus in the background
or in the foreground.
You could also have the
foreground be out of focus.
So if there was something
on this computer that
was really, really
interesting and I
wanted to have Dave as well,
I could have this be out
of focus and Dave in-focus.
It doesn't have to be that the
foreground is the one the thing
that's in focus.
And then the last
tip, and then I'm
going to turn it over to Dave.
And again, I understand
that this is all
abstract at this
point, but it's just--
I want to put some ideas out
there that will hopefully
inform some of the choices
that you'll be making later.
But the last thing
I want to mention
is framing in terms of centering
things or not centering things.
We tend to put
things off center.
This is an interview that we did
with Joel Dawson, a professor
in electrical engineering here.
Kind of dark on the screen, but
you see that he's off center,
and there's a lot of negative
space on the left, which
is where he's looking.
And that tends to
be-- and I'm talking
about very conventional
kinds of filming.
That tends to be
something that's
a little more pleasing, because
it gives the frame some more
energy.
Psychologically, I'm not
exactly sure why that's true,
but it might be that there's
space for him to potentially
move into rather than
being lined up right
in the center of the frame.
So he's looking into space that
he could potentially occupy.
Also, just as an aside,
notice that the background
is very, very soft.
It's shot with quite a
long lens, which is nice
because the interview subject
pops out number 1, and also
number 2, it was this very,
very unattractive lab.
And it just goes away.
It's very nice.
The other thing about
filming things off like this
is that you want to think
about, in terms of framing,
and this is, again,
classic composition.
Think about your
frame in thirds.
The third dividing lines--
if you take a line and
divide it vertically
and thirds and then
there's one line missing
here but horizontally in thirds,
the intersections of the lines
tend to be powerful
places in the frame.
And you notice here, again,
it's very classic framing.
His eye lines up exactly
with one of those third
places, one of
those intersections.
That's why when you have
close ups of people in movies
and it gets really,
really close,
they tend to chop
top of the head
off because they're keeping
the eye line roughly
in the top third of the frame.
You notice, again,
he's centered this way,
so there's a lot of
negative space over there.
You could just as
easily put them
over here looking this way
into the negative space
and his eye could be
lined up with that.
If it was a wider shot,
like a very wide shot, maybe
a head to body shot and
we saw the entire frame,
you would probably-- again,
if it was classic framing,
his head would end up being
in one of these third spaces
as well.
So imagine a whole body
with a head here or here.
And if they were walking and
you were panning with them,
if he was walking this way, you
would probably frame them up
on that line with his head
there, which would give him
plenty of space to walk into.
And then you would continue
to pan with him, always
giving more space here,
because again, that gives you
this energetic frame in the
sense that the person is
walking and you're following.
So that's the very, very
quick tour of some things
to think about when you
frame and choose shots,
and we will be spending a
lot of time in this class.
So don't think that you needed
to absorb it all right now.
But-- go ahead.
AUDIENCE: One of
things we realized
about having them
to be videotaped is
that in the future, it
becomes a chance then
that after you've
been playing around
with the camera at some
point, you can go back
and to have relistened
to this talk when--
it made more sense afterwards.
PROFESSOR: Right, right.
This will make the
most sense when,
as I said, not only
done some shooting
but also done some editing.
And between now and
then, we will definitely
be going back to talk more
about film language and film
grammar and the kinds of
shots that cut together
and the kinds of shots
that don't cut together.
I'm going to turn it over
to Dave in just a minute,
but I want to say one
last word about formats.
So formats in video are
proliferating like crazy.
There are an endless number
of HD SD, but at this point
primarily HD high
definition formats.
The one we're filming
or using in this class
is HDV 1080i 1440 by
1080, which is basically
a compressed version of full
HD, which is 1920 by 1080.
And you may know something
about what those things mean,
you may know nothing
about what they mean,
but I want you to
write them down
and you'll absorb them
later if that makes sense.
Basically, 1920 by 1080 refers
to the size of the frame.
It's 1,920 pixels wide by
1080 pixels high, which again,
if we go back to this
frame, that gives you
basically that aspect ratio.
So it's wider than it is high.
And that's 16 by 9
televisions, as opposed
to standard definition
square or televisions.
Our data rate is 25%
megabits per second,
and that boils down to
approximately more or less
10 gigabytes per hour.
And what that means, obviously,
is that the file sizes
are very, very large.
There's a lot of data.
The camera's capturing a lot of
data, the computer you edit on
is expected to
process a lot of data.
And one of the things that we
will be talking about later
in the class is how the
IT revolution has really
enabled video documentaries
and completely changed the game
and enabled things like
this class to happen.
The point here is mainly
just so that you're
kind of aware of the format
that these cameras shoot
and what the file
sizes are going to be.
That's also why we
give each of you
a hard drive so
that you don't have
to worry about how
you're going to store
a terabyte worth of
material on your own.
So any quick questions before
I turn it over to Dave?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is there--
the first one there--
so the framing-- how
to get their shape.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it's
basically squeezed.
But you never see it squeezed.
It actually then gets
uncompressed automatically
when it's viewed.
AUDIENCE: So we see as 1920?
PROFESSOR: Yes, you see the
same it looks like 1920 by 1080,
and the reason that they
compress it like that
is to save space.
So the 25 megabits
per second data rate
is very, very low for
high definition video.
Most data rates are higher
than that, like 35, 50, 55,
or for completely
uncompressed HD,
really I forget it's
really, really high.
So it's just a strategy
for giving less data
but still having
a nice HD image.
You never actually
see that, unless you
make a mistake in final cut,
which we can talk about later.
And just one word
about why we're using
tape in this era
of cards and files.
One reason is that the cameras
are a couple of years old,
but there's actually
another reason
to which is that this provides
a very cheap and easy backup
for you.
File management, as wonderful
as cards are and as much
as it speeds the process and I'm
a big fan of them, in a student
situation, if you want to do
cheap backups, tape is great.
TA: You can stick them
in your sock drawer
and not have to worry
about your hard drive
crashing or something.